here the nominees for Best Documentary
Short subject cave digger Jeffery car
off facing fear Jason Cohen
Kurama has no walls Sahra is the lady in
number 6 music saved my life
Malcolm Clarke and Nicholas Reed prison
terminal the last days of private Jack
haul anchor bearings the lady in number
6 music saved my life
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
when I met Alice summer I was struck by
two things her extraordinary capacity
for joy and her amazing capacity for
forgiveness for those of you who don't
know it
the amazing Alice sama died one week ago
today
she was 110 she died quietly and so this
really is and that they're both famous
she was a woman who taught everyone on
my crew to be a little bit more
optimistic and a little bit more happy
about all the things that were happening
in our lives and see the film she'll
help you live I think a much happier
life thank you so much thank you thank
you to the crew responds with our five
Fredericton
we call
[Music]
[Applause]